- We're sailing towards an iceberg,
this little white peak in the distance
getting closer and closer,
but really, it's been
underneath us the whole time.
There's nothing worse than a kid.
- We have some bad news on the case.
The print we lifted
from the victim...
is from your son.
- There's got to be
an explanation.
They go to the same school,
Jacob's in his class.
Yes, we know that.
- Lynn, have you arrested my son?
- Before we begin,
I want to make something clear.
A kid your age charged with
first degree murder...
is tried as an adult.
- I swear I didn't do it.
- We believe you.
- You have admitted to
being in the park,
and a fellow student alleges
you had a knife
- you would bring to school.
- I guess so.
- They're saying
he looked smug and remorseless.
This is gonna follow him around
for the rest of his life.
- It's a mistake.
We're gonna figure it out.
- Do you have any doubts
about Jacob's innocence?
- No, of course not.
- Where is the knife now?
- So you've been lying to me.
- I did what any parent
would have done.
Can't leave his fate
up to the courtroom.
My only job now is trying to
protect our son.
- We're prisoners
in our own home,
- acting like we're normal.
- We are normal.
Oh, my God,
you think this is normal?
- We gotta get
answers for ourselves.
I know what you did!
Lawyers have boundaries.
I don't. Not anymore.
- Remember that in their eyes
it isn't just Jacob who's guilty.
You all are.
- Did you follow me here?
- This is damaging.
This is evidence.
- You're scaring him.
- Good! He should be scared.
I'm scared!
- So I have to know.
I want the truth!
- You can be a good man,
or you can be a good father.
- There was no normal
to go back to.
There was just before...
...and after.
[indistinct shouting]